In this problem, given a list that possibly contains lists,
we want to count all of the elements in all of the lists.
So to go through an example, the black list has 2 elements.
This blue list has 3 elements, and the pink list has 2 more elements,
leaving us with the total of 7 elements.
So this is what we want to compute, and we can take a second to think about
how we're going to do that.
We're basically going to start with the length of this list,
and then we're going to iterate through each element
and repeat the process for every sublist.
Let me show you how that works.
We're going to start with our sum at 0,
and then we're going to iterate through each element.
For every element we see, we increase the sum by 1,
and if it's a sublist, we're going to do deep_count on the sublist.
Once we've gone through every list, we're going to return the sum.
[Mouth sound mimicing explosion] I've got to get like a catch word, like pow!